good
morning uh welcome to this babber
overview and scrutiny committee I am
councelor Mary McLaren and I am chairing
the meeting today may I first remind you
of some domestic
Arrangements if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to
leave please ensure your mobile phones
and laptop s are on silent additionally
we will be using EV voting for this
meeting on the modern doov do
app the council members of the public
and the Press May record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded if you are intending to do so
please inform the committee
clerk if you hear the fire alarm leave
the building immediately via fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is in ipswitch town football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits at each end of the
floor do not enter the atrium that is
the ground floor area and walkways if
you are in the atrium at the time of the
alarm follow the signs to the nearest
fire exit use the stairs not the lifts
do not reenter the building on until
told it is safe to do
so can I welcome the following people to
our meeting this morning in
attendance uh councelor John Ward who is
the cabinet member for finance assets
and
Investments Arthur javonia who is our
chief executive and Melissa rans
director for corporate resources and
section by1 officer and helping us with
the meeting is Alysia Norman who is our
lead officer for overie and scrutiny can
I move to the agenda
please apologies for absence and
substitutions uh no apologies received
chair uh to receive Declarations of
pecary other registrable or
non-registered notification of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition
scheme none received
chair questions by the public none
received questions by counselors none
received CH thank
you we now proceed to item six on the
agenda which is BOS stroke 23 stroke 01
the draft general fund to
to 25 assumptions I would like to invite
councelor John Ward the cabinet member
to intru introduce the report to the
committee thank you Council award thank
you madam
chairman you have in front of you the
report which provides the general fund
budget assumptions for the
20242 Financial
year we are currently on the basis of
these assumptions forecasting a deficit
of 1.5 million for the budget for that
that year and this Compares with that
the current situation for the present
Financial year where we're at the end of
quarter 1 forecasting an over spend of
£81,000 as opposed to budget um
prediction of
22,000
Surplus although we haven't yet uh
confirmed the quarter 2 numbers at
cabinet it's likely to show worsening
from that £81,000
there are a number of factors that have
gone into
the these assumptions and you'll see
there are one or two really significant
items here firstly of course the the pay
reward increments and the pay review
this is a combination of both the 2023
to 24 pay award um but also um the the
2024 25 uh payward assumptions of
4% the other big uh contributive factor
is the um uh the reduction in planning
income that is significant um we are
forecasting for the current year and
this has had an impact on our current
year um uh forecasts of of a reduction
in planning fee income of over £400,000
and this is likely to continue into the
next year which is why we're showing
this in in table
one we also have an increase in
short-term borrowing rates the the rate
now is
5.5% so all in all that um provides an
assumed increase in cost of uh next cost
of service for 2024 to 25 of just over 2
million 2.2 million set against that
there are some savings the principal one
is and uh this is yet to be confirmed
but should be later this week at suffer
public sector leaders that um SPS o will
not be top slicing from the pulled
business rates and that this year as we
did a couple of years ago during covid
the individual Burrows and districts
will retain their portion of that uh
pulled business rate so that will will
enable another £700,000 to come back to
us which will reduce the overall
forecast deficit from that 2.2 million
down to the 1.5 million you'll see at
the bottom of the
table there are still um pressures on on
future years and um you the medium-term
picture is currently showing a deficit
Precision of 2.5 million for 25 25- 26
and 3 million for 26 to
27 as a result uh of the situation in
the forecast uh currently that's likely
to increase both of those numbers
increase quite substantially so you'll
see we've got a lot of work to do in
order to balance our
budget um but we will have we will get
there we have to get there but at the
moment we have these budget assumptions
which we must address thank you madam
chairman thank you Council
award qu questions from committee
members councelor
Wyman thank you chairman councilor Ward
um on the table one uh particularly my
question centers particularly around the
pay award and the Assumption of
4% um bearing in mind the inflation
rates and the
overall um impact of of let's call S job
movement generally between local
authorities Etc
a question one is is our assumption
sufficient and
accurate B have we factorize into that
the cost of of job movement I.E if we
lose People based upon say a slightly
inadequate um pay award and then we end
up having to try and find new people I.E
the cost of recruitment embedding people
into the council training
Etc thank you Council Wyman certainly in
terms of the um the increments um that
that have been agreed uh on this is
based on primarily on the the national
um nationally negotiated increments plus
also our own internal pay review we we
know the numbers from those and and from
from both of those the the numbers are
are accurate as to the impact of any
movement of staff and and loss of staff
and and rehiring um that's really not
something um it it's it's difficult to
to forecast the impact of that I I would
say wouldn't you Melissa it's yeah yeah
yes I it's not it's not in these numbers
no it's not um the next item down you'll
see we've got m a vacancy management
factor of 5% so we've got an allowance
in there for staff turnover if you like
so when somebody leaves if it takes two
or three months or somebody's on three
months notice of the job they're coming
to then predominantly there is a bit of
a saving there because we don't fill
that post and we try to cover it within
existing staff obviously when somebody
joins there is a negotiation we tend to
or our policy is to appoint at the
bottom of the grade when we appoint
someone new but obviously that is a
discussion to be had when somebody is
recruited to a post so there's nothing
built in there apart from the staff
turnover
numbers
yes my my sort of Point really was
there's like a sweet spot on the payward
and the payward needs to contribute I'm
not asking the question now really I'm
Sor I apologize that but the the PIR W
it needs to be at the right point
doesn't it you know if we if we don't
spend sufficient here it's going to cost
us way more over here and the impact of
that for the council as to whole can be
quite you know there's impact to it and
it's important to make sure that the
payward is as good as it possibly can be
at the same time we don't lose people
and incur cost in relation to um
having to
recruit I we'll let the um the chief
executive um come back on this but
firstly I think from from the pay review
that we've conducted we have addressed
all of the um anomalies that were in the
system up until now and and um we've
we've come up with a um a new pay
structure which is is fit for purpose
and and go for going forward but um you
got to remember that people leave and
and move around from job to job for a
number of reason reasons um and we we
can't cope with any every eventuality
there so um uh there there's there's
going to be a general churn anyway but
um Arthur if you want to pick up on that
yes thank you I don't know whether
there's have any assistance or not so
the pay review that we've done this year
is something we don't want to have to do
very frequently um but that's allowed us
to at least make sure that we are uh at
a on a Level Playing Field with other
local authorities and particularly other
shared local authorities so hopefully
that will assist with exactly what
you're talking about the pay award
element which is the annual inflationary
amount is outside of our gift um so
that's set nationally um through
negotiations uh between the employers
and employees with unions um and so in
that respect that that isn't one we can
directly control I'd like to be able to
then we could put some certainty into
our budget and we' know what number
we're working with whereas in reality we
have to put a guess best guess into the
budget and then see what plays out
through those negotiations but at least
I suppose the one advantage of it being
set nationally means that you haven't
got that competition further exacerbated
where one local Authority pulls away
from another as it
were thank you
you councelor
Jameson thank you
J
John Al um looking at unless I'm
misunderstanding looking at your the
table one there doesn't seem to be any
assumptions made for gas electric and
fuel cost Rises now based on current
situation there's they're likely to rise
I would have thought um I just want
there that's is that not being infected
in
or councel James there is a line for
fuel costs um it doesn't the assumptions
boxes are blank oh I see what you mean
yes yeah there there's just um uh a
numerical impact there there's nothing
here yeah no a blanket yeah it's not
it's different for each contract yeah
there are a number of separate contracts
in there and and and usage profile so
there's there's no single number that
all right so we can factor in fuel those
those sort of cost Rises well all all
we've we've put in is um is an impact of
another £3
38,000 um in the in the final column
there right okay
then
councelor
grandon thank you madam chairman um I
have two questions if I may
please um the first one is um why have
we assumed for a zero um council tax
increase and we know that we will be
increasing
um a
percentage why have we assumed zero
instead of of assuming a central
percentage um
Point what we have here a list of all
the assumptions that are going to um
affectiv the actors as the pressures on
on the budget for next year at the
moment we haven't made any decision over
um how we're going to address th those
those pressures either through council
tax or any other uh changes to um fees
and charges the the um the
Administration has not yet agreed as to
what it's going to do on council tax so
so consequently we can't put in a number
just yet mention the government hasn't
said how much oh and yes and also the
government hasn't um because we haven't
had the settlement for this year we
don't yet know whether um the 2.99%
limit is going to be retained or whether
the limit will be
changed but doesn't it make our our
figures look worse when you haven't put
in you know an assumed you know like a
middle rate sort of thing um or even an
assumed lower possible percentage it
just seems that we we're by by putting
in zero and we know that we won't charge
have a zero increase um that it it it
makes our figures look far worse than
they actually need to be because we know
we will be that we'll be allowed to
charge something a
percentage um and it seems seems to
be allowing us to make our our
um you know our outcomes seem far worse
than than it need be really and that's
quite a big or or reasonably big um
difference to to our final
figure it just seems an odd accounting
method really but please
explain um really what we've got here is
the the size of the challenge facing us
that1 1.5 million P deficit has to be
Zero by the time the budget goes to
council because we can't run a deficit
budget so what you're look what you're
talking about are the ways we're going
to um bring that down from 1.5 million
deficit to zero council tax uh will will
be one of
them there are if you'll see on page
seven um under under the uh The Heading
band D increase there's an indicative uh
number here um two IND indicative
numbers uh one for 2.99% 1.5 for5 pound
increase which show you the kind of
increases that that those uh two council
tax options will provide and you can
take those numbers off the 1.5 million
pounds um to to get an idea of the
impact of council tax on on reducing
that
deficit may I ask my second question
please please thank you um yeah my
second question is um it appears that
planning the planning income is one of
our um areas where
um we have a big bigger deficit than we
had hoped has it to to um improve that
forecast has it been considered to use
um
external
Consultants um as shortterm measure
instead of current
Spa that um planning um fee income
represents a reduction due to the U far
smaller workload due to far fewer
applications coming in so uh
that's I'm I'm not quite sure of what
you're trying to
so um at the moment because there are
fewer um applications coming in
um where
um it would be a sad thing to do of
course and we have some excellent
officers but has it been considered to
possibly lose some of those officers to
decrease costs um and if a shortterm
need comes in um to look at external
Consultants um to cover any
temporary um um increas in need if if we
do have to lose some
stuff I understand exactly what you're
saying councilor grindon um you you're
straying into Political decisions over
solutions to the problem um and and
these are decisions that we're not in a
position to um um to to finalize yet but
obviously everything has to go into the
mix when trying to address the problem
we have facing us sorry yes I understand
thank you very
much councelor
Riley oh there we
are
[Music]
thank you madam
chairman and
uh councilor Ward good morning to you
I'll go back to council gon's question
um second question
is we're not getting the planning fees
that we
expect and the reason being that
developers are not coming forward with
plans for housing businesses and so on
so question is what are we doing to make
Bay back more
attractive to
Developers for and more attractive for
businesses coming forward I mean you
know we're showing here that we've got
continuing deficits 921,000 2.5 million
3 million we are just planning to
overspend our income for three years
onwards so we need to have strategic
action in place is to bring down these
deficits and show how we are living
according to our means which is what
we're not doing you and so the question
comes back again if uh planning fees are
a key element and there are other key
elements here um what are we doing to
address this
problem or sess the
situation A A lot of the uh issues not
so much um uh things that we are not
doing it's the um the current economic
climate developers uh are postponing
their plans and and not coming forward
with planning applications um our new
local plan which is going to council
tomorrow um for
adoption uh sets out our development
policies for the the next 15 or so years
um and I would contend that that uh does
demonstrate that babber is is a a place
where
development of the right sort is very
welcome and that will
con the policies in that plan will
determine the way that development will
take place over the next 15 years or so
both for residential and Commercial
development thank you uh councilor Ward
um don't quite understand these bracket
we we
show we show sorry pay Seven bottom of
pay seven business rate
uh we show figures in Brackets as
income which I'm trying to get my head
round um can you take us through this
savic leaders to consider proposal not
to top slice from the pool business
rates and this apparently get us income
of
700,000 uh yes I did touch on that in my
introduction um so you will see here um
in the uh second right column the
various
business rate components the income
we're getting or we're forecasting
getting in the current budget and uh
we're we're making an assumption that
it's going to be pretty much the same
going forward you'll see there's a a
pooling benefit item there of £ 457,000
what happens is um all of the suffk
authorities um together um benefit from
pooling their business rates some of
that goes back to the individual
authorities and some of that is top
sliced for suff public sector leaders to
spend on projects that benefit the
county as a
whole and and we get that suff public
sector leaders gets that every
year what we're proposing for 24 to 25
is that that top slicing that goes to
suff public sector leaders does not and
is instead retained by the individual
districts and Burrows and and
County so that's why we get another on
top of the the current um rollover um
forecast for various business rates
income we we're adding on another
£700,000 because that's no longer
assuming that gets approved by stuff
public SE leaders on Friday that will no
longer go to spsl it will be retained by
bab right so
that's addressing our deficit it's a
oneoff um to address the particular
pressures we've got this this year as
indeed as I said we did the same thing
two or three years ago in in 2021 in
covid when we had uh significant
pressures there the decision was made
not to top slice and uh so uh we we
benefited at that point and we'll be
doing this so again next year thank
you have any more questions no more
questions thank you chair morning
everyone um on the topic of Staffing if
we were to call for voluntary redundancy
how would that square with mid saach who
were in a different financial position
with our shared
offices thank you yes you hit the nil on
the head it causes an immediate question
because staff are employed on one
contract but effectively work for both
authorities um so they may happen to be
on one Council contract or not but the
costs shared so if we make an individual
redundant uh then obviously you have
half the saving roughly speaking for
babber as a result of that post being
lost but equally mids save that post as
well another way of looking at it if
miduk didn't want to lose that post you
could transfer the whole of that post to
become a mids suffer employee and no
longer providing shared work with babber
that's possible starts to cause some
headaches from a managerial perspective
as you can imagine uh if you've got
situation where some staff work for one
but not the other and lots of Staff work
for both uh it starts to get more
complicated but not impossible I think
my main concern around around volunteer
dundy would be the um inconsistent way
in which that brings people forward um
because what that's not doing is
matching your political priorities uh
and resourcing accordingly it's an
individual saying I'd like to go um well
actually I might really need to keep you
and really I can afford or make a
difficult decision uh to lose somebody
else in a different team so I would
rather not go down the voluntary don't
see but you're right as as the leaders
leader set out we're going to have to
make some difficult decisions in order
to balance the books
questions the privilege of the
chair um first of all um when we looking
at the um vacancy
management
factor I have not seen any cost for
temporary staff or intering directors is
that information
available it's not something we would
tend to put in a paper like this and
what tends to happen with uh temporary
staff costs is that's offset against the
vacant post if you like so it's already
in the establishment so it'll be just
set against that cost if you like is it
possible is it possible Melissa to see
that uh yes just over a period of a year
yeah yeah we can do that I would I would
welcome that CU I don't remember seeing
that thank you very
much um when we go on to supplies and
the gas and electric and the
fuel what has been the benefit and is it
demonstrated in this paper by reducing
the overall um space that we're using we
lost lime didn't we and we've gone into
gold
only what what Financial benefits have
been to us from that and has that
impacted on the this sort of um Supply
system we certainly had reduction in the
um rent we had to pay and and also the
service costs we had to pay for the the
uh space we occupy here at Endeavor
house these numbers that relate to our
other um premises they don't they depos
and there isn't that is will be in there
as well is it yeah
um so
so in terms of the the rental income
savings that where where are that will
be in there that be in the premises in
the premises in the premises cost it not
actually in there but in the budget it
it's on the premises so it's not here on
on this particular table
no to you go back to that Council award
it would be interesting to see what
benefit we have gained by I mean that
was the reason we yes um I do have the
numbers somewhere but not not um not
immediately to hand unless no Arthur do
you have that not the numbers I have a
figure in my head I'm not going to quote
it in case it's wrong um but certainly
uh if you take away the fuel element for
a moment or the energy cost element for
a moment half the rent half the business
rates uh half the facilities management
costs because we are occupying half the
amount of space so there's a clear
saving there in terms of the actual uh
fuel energy costs we have to go and have
a
look it does raise the question about
what was the benefit
the financial benefit considering this
is you know an important review thank
you um back to the shared legal service
that is something that um I think when I
was chairman last time we reviewed um
again I'm looking for some costs on the
shared leag how is it I know it's three
councils how is it broken down into the
the costs of the shared legal
service
um so I can't remember what the exact
percentage uh split is but it's based on
kind of the work that that West suff do
for uh bab and mids suffk so it's it's
based on on the churn if you like of
case load that goes through um so it's
it worked out on that split is it
because we did review it at this
committee um it might be worth sort of
looking at those figures if that's
possible thank you
Melissa the last question sorry
um the planning income which of course
we're all concerned
about I raised this the other day
actually in a different meeting about
planning income but what happens if
those plans have been approved by the
planning
committee uh the developer then pulls
out of that or just doesn't do how does
that impact the income say from you know
the new homes bonus and the sill and all
that because certainly I was somewhere
yesterday talking about developers I
mean a lot of them are facing really
Financial uh struggles if the if the
already approved plans are not
completed what's what's the impact of
that well obviously um it'll have an
impact on on our housing Supply years
going forward and it will have an impact
on seal because Seal's not payable until
work commences and then there's
uh usually a schedule of sale payments
throughout the development um there are
obviously a number of applications that
have been um approved so so far which
have not been started yet um we we have
no way of determining uh when a
developer is going to commence an
application and we just have to uh
assume at some point that they will if
if not if the application lapses then
there'd have to be a further application
in the future
I mean that that's a big consequence
actually yes yeah um obviously in terms
of sill yes um uh new homes bonus less
so because um that that is is tailing
off and we're not sure if if we're going
to get any next year and years going
forward at all um but it the the the
biggest impact of course will be on on
our council tax income because we we
won't have the the the growth in the tax
base um and of course the the worst
impact is um we won't be building the
the homes that people need and that be
contributing to house price inflation um
housing uh availability shortage and and
all of the the consequences arising from
from those um just going back I do have
the Endeavor house costs in front of me
if you're interested
in um so the lime and gold foot plates
uh were costing us £64,000 a year in
rent um and £200,000 service charge the
second floor rent was um n just under
£10,000 uh perom rent um and the service
charge was five just over £5,000 perom
gold foot plate the rent is £82,000
perom so that's the half of the lime and
gold but also we no longer um occupying
the second floor space and the service
charges £17,500
perom so significant we're talking about
um uh 50% more than 50% given that we'
given up the second floor uh reduction
in both rent and service
charge thank you Council
award any more questions sorry councelor
Wyman thank
you thank you chair to both councelor
Riley's point on development generally
and the loss of Revenue and also to the
chair's point in relation to our
planning position and applications that
that are being made it's a sort of
semi-political question and a semi sort
of process question which is you know do
you think the the uh the pace of change
between
jp1 and the addition of jlp part two
will create a Hiatus of like unknowing
between people who want to make
development decisions over the next six
months or a
year I I wouldn't have thought so um the
JP part one will clearly set out our
development management policies um and
uh it's those that uh applications will
be assessed against part two in terms of
um special distribution site allocations
that sort of
thing
I uh developers and and other applicants
can always come forward with with sites
whether they are um uh currently
recognized sites or or not not
um and and um those applications will
will be assessed against the the
development control policies we've got
um obviously we want to speed up and
expedite JP part two as quickly as
possible so we have some certainty over
that um over where the the development
will take place but um I don't think
that uh the time is going to take to to
to adopt that is going to have any
impact on um how often and um
application come forward from developers
that they will bring applications
forward to to suit their um their their
business
plans so politically and and from an
executive perspective we're quite
content then that the pace of change and
the pace of the the settlement of part
two won't be an impediment to our
planning uh processes and
fees I don't think it would be an
impediment no um but that's that's not
to say that I don't want it completed as
quickly as possible because I do want
certainty over um the particularly site
allocations and and how individual
communities are going to develop in in
the forthcoming years because we we we
owe that to to our residents to for that
certainty so that they know where uh
development will will be um expected to
take place but you also got to remember
we've got a substantial number of
neighborhood plans that have been
approved so so far and and they do for
the most part allocate sites at within
their own individual communities so we
do have some some knowledge uh from from
the neighborhood
plans good answer thank you
chair Al sir thank you chairman I was
just going to add one thing the the
slowdown in terms of planning fee income
uh isn't a babber issue it's a national
issue uh and so effectively where we are
with our joint local plan as the lead
has outlined shouldn't have a bearing
significantly so much as the impact of
the economy that's the thing that's have
a direct drag if you like in terms of
that planning applications and
particularly major applications coming
forward um so as we see the economy
recover hopefully we'll also see our
planning fee income recover in line with
that as
well councilor
Riley
hoping um for uh planning income raising
fees by
25% um are you aware oh yeah question um
how does our proposed new fee compare
with those not of our competitors but of
our
neighbors in mids suff suff Coastal and
whatever I mean how we how does this
increase make us more attractive equally
attractive or less attractive
the uh 25% for minor developments 35%
for major developments was a government
announcement very recently so that that
applies across the
country sorry again for me the 25%
is 25% for minor um applications 35% for
Majors these that's but okay fair enough
all right so the answer is we don't know
okay fair
enough chairman no the answer is not we
don't know the answer is we don't set
planning fees government set planning
fees and government have just increased
uh planning fees as a result which is
great news shame they didn't do it about
seven or eight years ago but nonetheless
they' finally increase planning fees
that will help mitigate in part but
clearly not substantially given the
reduction in the planning applications
and and just further to that that um
straying into the political Arena um you
yet again the government has set that
nationally but the district council's
Network and District B councils have
been lobbing for a long time for us to
have that ability to set those fees
locally so that we can reflect local
market conditions unfortunately the
government has not allowed us to do
that
[Music]
councilor
Jamon
thanks contracts um are these the only
contracts we have or or and
um can they be broken down further for
and also like the contracts relating to
our
housing um does that come out of H or is
that included in this as
well um no that's not all of our
contracts though the ones we've picked
out there are just the most significant
ones um we do publish our contract
register on the website site so you can
see there a list of all the contracts
we've had but most of them are fairly
insignificant in terms of increases um
so that wouldn't have a significant show
there um sorry your other question was
um cont oh the H sorry yes that will
that will sit in the H anything to do
Building Services will be contracts in
the H so on the website actually breaks
down the cost of each of the contracts
uh yes it does yes so it has each
contract there the length of the
contract um in there as well okay
thanks
any more questions
members we come to the end of the
question who would like to start the
debate councelor
Wyman thank you chair um I think you've
made a
compelling argument for some serious
scrutiny of how we look at our revenue
streams
and we are effectively whether you like
it or whether you don't Quai government
business and we generate income through
various streams um so my general point
is that we do need to look really
closely at how we manage our income
because the trajectory towards a serious
deficit is is really on the cards and we
need to look really really closely at
how we um manage our finances and where
we generate income
from check were you actually going
to propose that as a
recommendation I'll consider as a
recommendation okay thank
you more com
members
Council um I just that we're obviously
not alone in this situation this is
affecting councils nationally um and I'm
sure we're keeping a breast of what
other councils are
doing to try and fend off this situation
um and um we we should keep you know
keep a close eye on what other councils
are doing and the national situation
thank you
councilor councelor Riley did you have
anything to no contribute councilor
gron
Jam well I would like to just say um
about the report which was very
helpful um I've got to say Melissa to be
honest that that what we had the other
day helped with that that that pre um
that presentation that we had the other
day was really helpful to explain all of
that but we do have some serious
decisions to make as a council and I
think we need to be all aware of
that Alysia are we ready to go to the
recommendations yes chair so in the
report itself um there's
recommendation 2.1 which we'll keep
which reads uh that the draft budget
assumptions are set on in the report for
the 20242 general fund budget be
noted and then the other
recommendation that we have is one that
was proposed from councelor Wyman which
um I have written down here and feel
free to change it before we vote that
the director for corporate resources
further assesses how the council
managers is income to further decrease
for general fund
deficit
now for the first chair sorry my my
point was I just really think we need to
look very very closely over and above
what we are already doing we've got
compelling information that tells us we
need to make good that deficit and we
need to look at every strand of
potential income that we can generate
throughout the
organization councilor Wyman you're
making that as a proposal can I have a
second please for councelor Wyman
thank you chair so members those are the
two recommendations that I just read out
for one that's in report and one
proposed by councelor Wyman does anyone
need me to read them out again or are
we okay that's fine so Council lman
you're happy to propose both um the
recommendation and the report and your
own recommendation that's fine
cool um one
second okay members that vote is now in
progress on
modov
y That's
fine four thank you
um okay thank you members chair that is
six votes for so that is
unanimous in uh completes um
agenda item
six uh we will now go to the item seven
but can I thank
um Council a Ward and Melissa and Arthur
for presenting and helping us with those
decisions thank you very
much we go on to item seven of the
agenda BOS 23 stroke 02 forthcoming
decisions
list do members have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions
list you don't have to vote on
any comments
members none uh thank you the fourth
coming de decisions list is for
noting
only item 8 BOS stroke 23 stroke 03
babber overview and scrutiny work plan
do members have any
comments
no
yeah I come back to that in a minute
Madame chairman uh I'm very pleased to
see that in January we will now receive
an update on the progress regarding cor
slain because I was previously
understood given to understand that um
the on was not an appropriate body and
I'm pleased to see that this is now
being acknowledged that we are an an
appropriate body to look at these things
um and hey that's great we're all and I
look forward to the information and
scrutiny that we can give to this uh
project uh we did ask for information on
um where we were with officers working
from home um and so on and what
productivity was um and this was carried
forward and I was now given to believe
that and as see he's left
now which is a shame quote the chief
executive has advised that he has access
to these numbers and is reported to all
members at the annual all member
briefings and you will look to set up a
briefing soon when this data will be
made available to you uh Madam chairman
I'd like to underline the fact that when
we ask these questions when I ask these
questions I ask the questions on behalf
of this committee um who in turn uh
respond because we are here on behalf of
our residents so I I you know I take it
very dimly when um the
officers slide their way out of this and
tell us that we are not an appropriate
body and I'd like to underline the fact
that we ask these questions
so we can find
out only what the council is doing but
so we can be happy with what they are
doing we expect to receive good news
this is not a bear trap that we set to
cause embarrassment you know we expect
good news we expect to know the council
is on top of its problems and that's why
we ask the questions so we get these
answers
otherwise you not giving us answers
let's us assume the worst and and that's
what happens here so I would like Madam
chairman to put this back again and put
it in for January that we would like to
know where we are with working from home
as we all know you come in here on a
Monday or Friday it's like boarding the
Mary
Celeste you know the place is empty
compared to others and you can tell how
bad it is because the Friday fishing
chip day has been moved to
Thursday yeah so M chairman I'd like to
come bring this back now to uh this
committee and I'd like it to be
scheduled for
January thank you councelor Riley I've
noted all your comments and as you know
I'm always eager to respond to comments
and we'll come back we'll come back with
some proactive response to
you thank
you
Ron thank you madam chair if we do go
along that route of examining the um
staff working from home and otherwise um
might it be useful to have a comparison
of
pre I don't know preco
or a
a there um you know zero date and
today's date you know on productivity
um some form of measurement is what I'm
I'm seeking so that we're not just
looking at the number of Staff who are
working from home but how it affects
productivity how it affects
um um Communications you know if a um
resident calls up a particular dep
Department um does it affect
Communications um regarding ing um
contacting members of Staff who are
working from home and so on so we're not
just looking at um straight numbers of
who's doing this and who's doing that
but what it's whether it is having any
effect on the way the council operates
and its interactions with residents and
so
on thank you councelor grandon I think
that's um a very useful comment to make
um an
observation um Alysia I'm just cating on
this at the moment do we need with this
particular subject do we need to do a
task and finish
group um looking to you for advice
actually um it really depends what uh
committee would like um my personal
suggestion as an officer would be that
we bring an information bulletin or a
report on this subject to committee
first um so we can have a look at the
situation and ask the questions that you
want to ask and then if you see that
there's an issue that you would like to
work on further then we can see about
putting together um a working group or a
task and finish
group because I think I'm listening to
to the committee members ERS um
certainly two of them are interested in
pursuing it to a greater depth uh and
detail and um I think we need to respond
to the committee's concern actually
um alysia's suggestion is that
acceptable to
you because it
would I'm sorry Alysia could you just
explain again how see that that that
that you would your your suggestion
could you explain your suggestion again
please sorry yeah of course no problem
so um so the item that councilor Riley
has
proposed um on this topic we will bring
back um in January or if it doesn't fit
maybe February or so definitely at the
next committee or two um we'll review
the topic in that format if um you come
across issues ues within that topic that
you want to explore further and you
think that maybe committee is not the
best place for it um we can put together
a task and finish group or a working
group that would be comprised of members
from this committee um and then we would
look to scope that um at a future
meeting of the task and finish group if
it was to be put together if that makes
sense councilor
Riley
I'm very concerned that we actually
continue to kick this problem down the
road into the long grass we understand
that the chief executive has access to
these numbers so we could actually ask
for them to be delivered within the week
because he has access to them and he
knows what they are so asking for them
in January is not a great hardship you
know let's have the figures let's have
whatever spin it needs to be put on them
let's show how much better we're doing
than preco or whatever pre- brexit
whatever Benchmark they wish to go and
use but let's have some figures let's
see where we're going and you know let's
see what we're doing the chief executive
has these figures you know we're not
asking for a great deal of
research January please I don't care go
to other working parties I've had enough
of working parties I can't control uh we
can't control we've asked for this
information once and now we're asking
for it
twice Let's
uh the first okay that's fine um the
only reason I say that it might not be
January is that we would have to discuss
whether mids want to look at this item
as well at the moment the January
committees look like they are going to
be completely separate um so we would
have to organize a joint meeting to do
it jointly which might not work whereas
we have a joint meeting already in the
diary in February so that is the only
reason that I suggest maybe February but
I can appreciate you wanting to get this
information in front of the committee as
soon as possible so I will have to take
away this conversation um obviously the
B committee are happy with it I will
have to talk to councelor Casten and
councelor scaf chair and vice chair of
mid to see if they want to do this item
as well and then we would if so we would
organize a joint meeting and I will have
to see how that works logistically if
they don't it will be a babon item and
it will come to January
hopefully no
grandon thank you um I wonder whether it
might be possible to discuss the kind of
areas that we would like the information
on now so that we're not going for you
so that we can once once you have found
out from U mids suffk whether they would
also like to explore this topic um
whether we can just go straight to the
paper rather than having to go in steps
would that
be possible to discuss the kind of
things that we would wish to
explore now Ro because that's two months
away yeah just to get to that first step
whereas um you know so essentially
scoping what you would like to see in
that paper is that what you're trying
to um not
now um at the mid suffk only scrutiny
committee uh this afternoon um I will
pose the question of adding this to the
mids suff work plans to that committee
and then once uh we have a agreed idea
whether it will be a babon item or a
joint um um I will definitely look to
discuss at the very least with the
chairs and vice chairs what that paper
would include but um as I know is a keen
issue for this committee as a whole I
would perhaps explore the idea of how we
could scope that as a committee ahead of
that report coming um my suggestion is
right now that hopefully we're going to
be doing training in a couple weeks for
the call in and we can extend that
session um if appropriate to discuss
this item as a committee as well as well
if that makes sense cool thank
you does uh is
that what you wanted he councelor BR yes
I'm very happy with that thank you I
think I mean I understand councelor
Riley's concern I've heard that and
that's been supported by Catherine
grandon but if we want to get effective
results we have got to do it properly
and and yes I understand you want to do
it straight away I'm not sure that's
wise let us look at the information let
us see if M suff are happy to work with
us on the same concerns and then and
then we proceed with a a proper uh
procedure that satisfies everybody is
that okay with you councelor
Riley yeah thank
you work plan
oh
so
sorry no problem chairman um I maybe
this may not be this may be an
inappropriate suggestion or or comment
really but on um the meeting on the 18th
of March 20124 when we're looking at the
um the local planning enforcement task
and finish group
recommendations would it be possible to
extend or ask that the scope of that or
is it too late to ask for it to include
the impact and embedding of jlp part one
and how that is affecting our decision-
making
processes uh yes so we are yet to um
properly scope that item in depth so
there is still room for us to add that
in if appropriate um that will probably
happen at the Joint chairs briefing um
which obviously you will be out so we
can explore that further with the
director and the corporate managers
the reason why I asked the question or
make the comment really is um it sort of
talks to the point that we made earlier
in relation to our finances and we need
to see some Pace in relation to Bringing
forward part two and the allocations and
how that's working and it will be fair
to say anecdotally that there is an
element of tension within the planning
department generally and our planning
processes uh which I see on a day-to-day
week to we B bis so that's the rationale
behind my
request councelor
Jameson just a couple of things so one
on on on that planning task on finish
group there I I probably missed it but
is that task and finish gr been set up
yet for that planning
enforcement is it me that's one thing um
off the top of my own head I'm not sure
um that is under the control of the
director of planning I don't think it
has been set up yet but it is um in the
very near future last time I checked it
should be about January February before
this item obviously comes to scrutiny
committee and the other thing back in
July of August when we were setting out
the work plan there was another number
of other items that we discussed we
wanted to bring forward and I can't top
my head I can't remember exactly what we
agreed in the end but I just wondered
where we are with the with all of those
topics
yeah of course not a problem so um
obviously the planning item in March is
one of four items that we proposed for
work plans uh we also proposed a item on
um Council services and how they're
being accessed by our residents both
online and in person Services um that is
being scheduled to come to February
there's an information bulletin at the
moment and I am still in talks with the
appropriate directors about um the item
on housing social housing obviously we
did our social housing tour the other
week so they're now building upon um
information from that tour to bring
forward and the town regeneration item
as well um I'm hoping looking at work
plans we've obviously got some space in
April and May at moment so those are
being held for those two items so
hopefully that will get put in motion
soon um we did um re reiterate several
times at the time that it wasn't just
planning enforcement we wanted to look
at planning as a whole yeah of course um
I think planning enforcement was just
the name I gave it um basically to cover
what was uh the majority in that um
scoping document but um as I said to
councelor Wyman there's only been sort
of brief discussions right now about
what that item is actually going to
entail that can be further scoped of
chairs briefing so an item comes to two
chairs briefings before it comes to
committee so if there are specifics that
you want explored within that report um
feel free to communicate them to me or
to counselor McLaren or Wyman who can do
that for you in the chair's briefing so
we can get that
included but um the directors have seen
the scoping documents that we put
together so they understand what was
written what was asked for in those
documents and they're hopefully going to
base their reports around the
information specifically requested by
yourselves of committee members any more
comments on the
plan thank you the uh overview and
scrutiny action tracker is for noting
only oh sorry sorry I understand there
was some queries in relation to Staffing
I'm not sure if I can help with those
while you're still here sorry I can't
hear you very well I understand there
was some queries in relation to Staffing
I'm not sure if I can help with those
while I'm while you're still here in
committee
Arthur I think
if at some point we come back to you
we've had a bit of discussion that's
fine I'd rather review that and then
we've got
something more
organized uh and we we've we'll come
back to you with what we've decided to
do and more than happy then to meet with
you yeah that's no problem chairman I
just wanted to remind councilors that on
an annual basis I bring forward a report
in relation to do all things Staffing uh
so that it doesn't come up at various
different committees at different times
happy to take in any suggestions as to
what could appear on that report and
equally happy to circulate the previous
version of it if that's of
assistance Bron's got a comment to
make I I just wonder whether it's worth
mentioning then at this point some of
the things that we were considering
bringing into a
future um meeting for for scope in
whether they would be things that were
allowed to scope then that maybe we can
mention this to arur now he's in the
room but I'm not sure
just um I think we've had the
discussions that we've had today I I
think are fine I appreciate we've just
got half a back and now I'm saying let's
let's not cover it but um I've taken um
all the points on board that were
discussed on this item and I I will
discuss them with the chief exec after
this and with a monit officer as well as
to how best to um have this item sort of
presented and scoped um we'll take the
outside the meeting and feedback to you
guys as a committee that's okay thank
you yes I think noting the concern of
members um I think we want to make sure
that we do it properly and then
everybody's questions and concerns uh
are raised and are answered and probably
today I don't think is the appropriate
time so thank you very much so that
concludes the business of this meeting
at
10:43